drop the weapon you drop the weapon okay
stay cool we can work this out I'm a
trained hostage negotiator I got my
friends sperm back from his ex-wife last
year well she destroyed half of it and
he decided to adopt but Peralta right
sorry what do you want you let me walk
out of this building you get into a car
if anyone tries to makes it 44 no no you
don't get credit for this guy I was in
the middle of negotiating and he was
about to give up tell him guy knows
probably gonna kill him
and let you kill me oh my god well I
should have been way more scared we go
take another crack at Whitman get in
there like five times what are you gonna
do annoy him into talking haha
two three four
[Applause]
didn't work queue the network we had an
epic night of bonding that I will never
forget do it I believe in you throw it I
believe in you I've been chasing this
guy for three months I've got him dead
to rights fingerprints witnesses it's in
the bag so I'm just gonna grab a healthy
breakfast those gummy bears wrapped in a
fruit roll-up
breakfast burrito but yeah I pity your
dentist ah joke's on you I don't have a
dentist planning your strategy no I'm
just making funny faces at him this
mirrored glass is awesome it's
straight-up works an effective use so be
a limited time it is actually that's how
I got him last time let him stew for a
little bit got in his head and he
confessed you better be right
I am hey make some funny faces while I'm
in there I want to see if I can tell
I didn't do anything joke that's fine
you said the exact same thing last time
and have that work out for you let's
take a look see what your trial you in
prison me media Regis Philbin that was
fun
you still in prison me at Splash
Mountain just pepper these in here you
in prison you in prison you in prison
you get it you got the wrong guy right
now ready to confess by inviting me I
got all the time in the world no you
actually have 48 hours I know the law
nah get it together man okay so the
story's hit about two hours ago they
took mostly tablets laptops and cameras
sorry I'd like a list of all your
employees whoever had access to the
store I'd also like to apologize for my
partner his parents didn't give him
enough attention uh detective I already
solved the case we're looking for three
white males one of whom has sleeve tats
on both arms and how do you know that I
had an informant on the inside he's been
here for years watching learning waiting
his codename fuzzy cuddle bear he's a
nanny-cam ah you got lucky no I got here
five minutes before you and figured that
in this gigantic electronics store there
had to be at least one working camera
oh hi bad guys you did it fuzzy you
busted him it's time to come home I'm
not sure if I can I've been undercover
so long I forgotten Who I am I have seen
terrible things I haven't known the
touch of a woman in many moons detective
Santiago don't walk away from me
borrowing those cars
bank account
account you should ask him about his
bank account captain
Santiago broke the glass the muggings
working fine a Cabot Street they began
over two months ago just like this
briefing did please go to charisma class
I'm here I'm here sorry Charles
no Jake never apologize for making an
amazing entrance my power went out last
night and my alarm didn't go off
your alarm is power dependent I brought
this on yourself son
point is it will not happen again carry
on sorry I'm late sorry - no hot water
this morning but I'm here ready to go
will cause no further distractions sorry
sorry sorry seriously what is your
Excuse today more bad luck my car ran
out of gas and then my clothes
disappeared from the laundromat I had to
beg one of my neighbors to loan me some
of his never told us Sinbad lives in
your building if soon bad lived in my
building I would have a tattoo on my
forehead that says Sinbad lives in my
building I'm here I'm here I'm here and
I'm a half an hour early that's right my
string of bad luck has finally come to
an end
Peralta you failed your drug test there
were traces of cocaine and
methamphetamines found in your urine
what if we catch Flaco and CJ gets
credit for it he's gonna transfer out of
the nine-nine that's what this is all
about
you're still trying to undermine the man
but no the opposite of anything I want
to see him succeed I'm trying to over
mine him oh you know I hate it when you
make up words Peralta are you still mad
at me for saying snacks identity is very
heads-up there's our perp looking home
her pee just perp in his way down perp
straight take a picture give me one
second my slides were really
unflattering for his complexion it
doesn't have to be perfect Tom Olsen is
a bad dude he's held up for electronic
stores at gunpoint and I wish you hadn't
read that Annie Leibowitz book we're
calling it a book where's a visual
journey you probably think I should
shoot this income instead of like a
light yes shoot color why have you been
shooting black and white where's he
going now
damnit NYPD freak
[Music]
you strapped
our foot chase my birthday wish finally
came true
there are five people responsible for
key collection in the city boom that's
our list of suspects we shall call them
the fellowship of the key
I honestly think you are the greatest
man who ever lived no that's a no-go
tracking these people down is a waste of
time I say we keep surveilling the
mailboxes look I have worked a ton of
these drug cases alright once they know
we're on to them they burn the whole
system trust me they're done with the
boxes trust me I am a federal agent
you're not FBI you're not ATF you work
for the post office your motto is
surprisingly we exist
incorrect our motto is knows custody
Mo's quod Lingus we guard what you lick
that's worse
are you too sure you should be
babysitting you seem real freaked when
you called me last night yes but then we
figured out how to be good parents TV
and cake TV and cake were my parents we
came here to win and they're not even
giving us a chance I think it's fair to
say that no one in the history of
America has been discriminated against
more buddy yeah that's might be
adrenaline talking see you guys in I
don't know I don't want to get in
trouble oh wow you sound like a real
Terry why don't you just take your shirt
off and make your pecs bounce around
again the adrenaline don't sue me enough
crooning can you get us a face-to-face
where we's yeah
but you gotta give me zero jail time no
that's not gonna happen haha stupid
cutie the DA however will offer reduced
sentence in return for Ruiz's arrest
five years instead of 20 oh that's tough
but fair I can see why you have such
intense daddy stuff with him oh yeah the
guy without a daddy is the one with
daddy issues explain that logic
Stabler awesome I will don't worry she's
gonna let Sarge follow him I'm gonna
stay right here I can't do it I'm gonna
cut him off me Ali
shortcut you just got jinx you okay no
search I got hit by a car
happy now broken ribs and a million
broken toes weren't enough for you in
retrospect they were plenty yes the
worst part is Olson got away that's the
worst part you could have died man
I wasn't hurt that badly the doctor said
all my bleeding was internal that's
where the Bloods supposed to be
I can't believe Leonardo lived in this
Michelangelo I get he's kind of a sloppy
dude but leo is so fastidious Jake shut
up Sarge we're in a sewer
I'm goats to talk about the Turtles
great news everyone we just got our
first lead on our first case on my first
night back proving once and for all that
absolutely nothing has changed yeah this
opens in instead of out now they
switched in a month ago yeah so the door
chains sure but that's it
Falcon one do we have a go the light is
green Tiger one what are you gonna say
when he crashed through the window hey
there sorry for dropping in Kirschbaum
shaken
goosebumps it's equipment secure check
weapon loaded check did you have
breakfast
what that's not on the checklist I added
it because I care about you no I did not
have breakfast unacceptable
look in your pocket hey there's a little
chocolate chips in this yeah I'm not an
idiot I know how to trick my best friend
into eating his fiber all right
bar digested mission go hey there sorry
for dropping in was the cool it felt
really cool yeah yeah it's pretty cool
pretty cool all wrong hey you'll have
fudge on cheek from the breakfast bar
boil
you